ich mach einfach das worauf ich lust
habe und versucht anderen menschen dabei
muss zugeben anders zu sein das macht
man den briten mit videos bei instagram
und tik tok sie macht ihre depressionen
und borderline erkrankung öffentlich und
zeigt ihre seltenen pigmentstörung
heute treffe ich net ingrid idee ist
deutschlandkarte stalkerin und wir
verbringen zusammen einen tag zuerst
frühstücken mehr und da vorne steht
nadine auch schon heiner die
schön dich zu sehen ich bin alisa
nadine ist 23 und ein selfmade internet
star vor etwa einem jahr wären corona
ging es für sie so richtig los als sie
viel zeit in ihre videos investieren
konnte weil ich habe mich auch wirklich
nicht getraut rausgehen ich habe heute
auch asthma und ich war wirklich viel zu
unsicherheit sich noch nicht meine
zweite impfung hatte aber als ich meine
zweite impfung hatte da ging es glaube
ich wirklich los mit man soll sie fällt
auf durch ihre pigmentstörung genannte
waldis muss und macht sie immer wieder
auch zum thema für nadine maß nicht
immer einfach zu den weißen strähnen und
stellen auf der haut zu stehen
[Musik]
sobald man halt so die kleinen babbel
wenn man auf praxis verlässt so im
urlaub klingt du deinen großstädten ist
damit man schon ganz schön blöd
angeschaut aber dennoch dachte ich mir
jetzt bei euch das thema jetzt keine
kurse mehr andern mir war es halt doch
schon irgendwie egal aber die kommentare
später als ich dann größer wurde im
internet bahn hat ganz schön böse sie
wird im netz gemacht versucht drüber zu
stehen
[Musik]
es war nie mein problem sondern das
problem der anderen hatte er das gefühl
ich finde es auch total schön so also
von mir auch dass ich mich getraut habe
jetzt damit selbständig zu machen obwohl
ist alle hin gefüllt fanden nun peinlich
aber es war mir halt egal und ich finde
seine egal einstellung ist gerade für
junge leute total wichtig doch da ist
noch mehr womit nadine zu kämpfen hat
während dem abitur werden ihre
depressionen immer stärker
ich hatte halt auch irgendwie so schon
so wirklich total grünen die gedanken zu
der zeit okay wenn ich das abitur nicht
schaffe bringe ich mich um es war so für
mich so ganz klar doch total sinnvoll
weil danach dachte okay wenn ich sowieso
nicht dafür habe ich ja eh keinen sinn
mehr habe ich dann irgendwie gerade so
noch geschafft aber ich meine emotionen
und mein lebensgefühl kam irgendwie
nicht zurück und dann bin ich in der
therapie gekommen aber ich habe heute
auch irgendwie gemerkt irgendwie stimmt
halt ich meine so klar depressionen zum
total schlimm aber ich hatte
wutausbrüche wegen in situationen die
nicht
nachvollziehbaren und halt auch er stand
bei meinem lieblingskünstler im
konzertsaal und ich habe nichts mehr
gefühlt und das war für mich glaubte
ausschlagen punkt wo ich mir dachte das
kann nicht wahr sein ich renne zum
nächsten therapeut und schreibt den
zettel und sagte was tatsache ist und
der meinte auch gleich nie irgendwas ich
glaube irgendwie persönlichkeitsstörung
und dann würde ich eine klinik
eingewiesen und erreicht dann auch drei
monate und genau die haben mich dann
wieder zurück ins leben gebracht das
heißt also es ist immer noch eine der
schönsten zeiten meines lebens ich daran
zurückdenke
sehr interessant zu hören endlich
gemerkt dass du sagst in der klinik war
die schönste zeit ja also warum
irgendwie war frühling und ich hatte auf
einmal hilfe und und hatte kein handy
kein internet und
nur sich selbst und irgendwie bücher die
einen das leben erklären und es hat mir
super getan damit leuten zu sein die
gleichen probleme haben und wirklich
natürlich sind die dunklen momente nicht
plötzlich ganz weg aber es geht besser
seit nadine damit ganz offen umgeht
ich wollte es gleich klar machen weil
mir waren diese kommentare einfach es
geht mir so auf die nerven wenn ich von
irgendwem hören muss sogar die peinlich
diese psychiatrie so das rettet
menschenleben und das hat mich damals
schon so genervt als ich in der
psychiatrie war und
man angst hatte dass jemand anderen zu
erzählen und da dachte ich auch gar
keinen fall da redet über wenn ich die
möglichkeit dazu haben
viele ihrer videos sehen aber auch so
aus leicht und unbeschwert das mischt
nadine auf ihrem kanal
[Musik]
wir ziehen weiter unser nächster
programmpunkt heute einkaufen in berlin
mit
dann suchen wir noch ein geschenk für
meinen freundinnen hatten in den
geburtstag doch dann treffen wir
zufällig tik tok freunde leveln und
lilly
[Musik]
dankeschön
nadine kommt nicht aus berlin trifft
hier aber immer wen den oder die sie
kennt
wen oder bei fotoshootings zusammen und
dann kennt er die über ecken kennt
eigentlich jeder jeden aber tatsächlich
halt
bei shootings zusammen genau und da
haben uns letztes jahr auch gesehen
setzte mal schon ein bisschen her mode
und beauty shootings das ist inzwischen
auch teil von der dienst leben online
wird sie oft von fans gefragt was sie
trägt das ist die heutige werden also
ich fand es total süß ich habe so fünf
sogenannte
die tasche genau wegen fiebers muss und
ja sie
achtet darauf pro tag mindestens drei
videos zu posten frequenz und reichweite
sind wichtig in dem job geld kommt über
kooperationen rein wenn man viele
follower und verloren hat nadine gibt
trotzdem nicht besonders viel aus sagt
sie
erfüllt endlich denkst du irgendwann so
grad in meiner situation bin ich sehr
sehr happy dass ich das es habe und dass
ich damit viel viel machen kann aber
ich würde sagen dass ich glücklich bin
als zwei jahren
ich würde mir jetzt auch niemals einen
porsche holen oder man kann ich mir
nicht leisten aber ich war halt immer
noch in meinem mini auto durch die
gegend weil das hält er war schon fünf
jahre lang und verbraucht wenig sprit
sind zwar nicht so cool aus wie ein bmw
oder weiß ich nicht aber ich habe ich
halt nicht nötig kann damit wenigstens
ein paar
zudem druck ständig zu posten kommt noch
dazu druck immer perfekt dabei
auszusehen viele nutzen dafür filter
nadine auch
also wie die die haut jetzt verfeinern
platter macken oder weiße zähne wir sind
halt auch so eine insel ist die man
leicht weg machen kann aber ich würde
jetzt versucht auch davon wechsel kommen
auf instagram erster diese filter die
das ganze gesicht verändern also so was
mache ich auch gar nicht also da bleibe
ich auch von weg und ich hatte auch eine
phase wo ich das gemacht hatte also da
kam ich auch gar nicht weg und diesen
filter zu benutzen und das war irgendwie
ein bisschen
mehr auch unangenehm aber
genau also man kann ich stehe dazu offen
dass sich facebook nutzer genau und auch
meine zähne bisschen weiter machen aber
ich
denke mal dass das irgendwie auch
menschlich weil meine arbeit geht
dadurch schneller unterwegs also
selbstkritisch aber ich versuche jetzt
auch nicht komplett mein aussehen zu
verfälschen aber es ist leider nur mal
so wenn du
hässlich ist in den augen anderer dann
werden
erklärt und ist auch ein großer druck
ich verstehe auch deswegen vielleicht
warum sich ja die eine oder andere
operieren aber ich will jetzt ein
beispiel nicht
nadine will künftig bei youtube noch
mehr von sich zeigen mehr aus ihrem
leben teilen april hat sie eine
assistentin damit sie nicht mehr alles
allein machen muss zeit für so ein
geschenke bummel oder hobbys hat nadine
selten sagt sie
also ich
total gerne aber ich komme irgendwie
nicht mehr zu hause alle habe ich die
ich jemals hatte sind jetzt eigentlich
führten gegangen habe und dass ich keine
zeit hatte dann haben wir noch etwas
besonderes vor nadine möchte gerne in
eine ausstellung mit licht farben und
sounds sie hat davon bei tik tok gehört
also ich würde mich schon als künstlerin
sehen und ich wollte auch immer eine art
kunst machen ich habe auch in manchen
videos auch für gemalt oder und faltiger
auch so fei kuchen an im tecdax und das
ist schon eine art ist damit klar dass
sich jedes tik tok jetzt eine kunst aber
es ist ein werkzeug braucht man kunst
machen
wieviel kunstfigur steckt in der dienst
videos und wie viel davon ist sie will
ich zum schluss wissen
ich würde sagen weil ich bin halt schon
noch alle jetzt gerade auch jetzt beim
ein happy videos und soja wenn du
glücklich bist deine ausstrahlung hast
kommt es wieder besser an
also ich würde schon sagen griff die 14
das war ein tag offline mit nadine
beauty ihre zukunft erträumt sie sich so
also ich mehr zeit und mehr arbeitet
es kamen wieder des jahres zu kurz auch
wegen krone